- Mathieu Trudel habite
un logement subventionné
aux immeubles H.S.F
depuis 5 ans.
- Sérieusement c'est
une belle place, c'est le fun.
- Mais lui et sa femme devront
peut-être partir.
Immeuble H.S.F, tout comme son
partenaire Milieu de vie TCC
de Québec sont menacés de
fermeture après avoir été
largués par leur assureur
à la suite d'un sinistre.
Desjardins n'a pas voulu
renouveler le contrat
d'assurance de la copropriété.
L'institution a proposé
un sursis de 3 mois devant
la difficulté du syndicat
à trouver un assureur.
Des primes qui augmentent
de 300 %, des franchises
astronomiques. Moins d'une
dizaine de compagnies acceptent
d'assurer les grands immeubles.
VINCENT GAUDREAU, courtier
en assurance de dommage
- Au-centre-ville, dans les gros
immeubles, on voit souvent des
franchises de 100 000, 250 000.
- Pour la Maison Martin Matte,
de Québec, qui prend soins de
gens souffrant de traumatismes
crâniens, impossible de suivre
la cadence.
DENIS DOYON, Milieu de vie TCC,
Maison Martin Matte
- C'est sûr qu'avec ce qui s'est
passé, les augmentations
de prime sur lequel on est
actuellement confronté
avec les augmentations
des franchises, ça met
complètement l'organisme
en péril au niveau
de sa survie et à court terme.
SANDRA MOLLOY, vice-présidente
des immeubles H.S.F
- Nous, on ne vit qu'avec les
loyers puis on ne peut pas
les augmenter nos loyers parce
qu'on est régi par la SHQ,
donc ça va être la mort
des organismes, ça va être
la mort de H.S.F.
- En plus, d'ici avril 2022,
les copropriétés doivent
capitaliser un fond équivalent
à la plus haute franchise,
résultat de la loi 41
passée l'an dernier.
YVES JOLI-COEUR, avocat
spécialiste en copropriété
- Les syndicats de propriétaires
deviennent somme toute un peu
leur propre assureur.
Quand on parle de franchise
d'un quart de millions
de dollars comme dans
le cas ici, alors c'est-à-dire
qu'à chaque fois qu'il y a
un sinistre, la majorité
des sinistres, bien c'est
le propriétaire qui doit
l'assumer.
- Selon l'avocat,
le gouvernement devra mettre
un plafond aux franchises.
- Le gouvernement du Québec
a le devoir de démontrer
son leadership en cette matière
parce qu'on est en train d'être
dans un marché qui va être
difficilement assurable
et la situation se détériore sur
le terrain et ça prend
absolument que le gouvernement
s'en mêle.
- Parce que sans aide,
les résidents de cet immeuble
pourraient bien se retrouver
à la rue.
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-Comeau
Radio-Canada, Q